beijing ha bajado hoy la persiana a sus
juegos olímpicos de invierno con una
ceremonia sobria ha sido unos juegos
marcados por la geopolítica por el
boicot de eeuu y cuatro países por la
reunión del primer día entre sí siempre
ni vladimir putin y por la amenaza de
una invasión a planeta y nunca amigo
caminas en los juegos marcados por el
korn habidos por la burbuja en la que
han vivido durante dos semanas los miles
de participantes por las pruebas pcr
diarias y por los funcionarios en trajes
de protección integral el mecanismo ha
funcionado los 400 positivos fueron
detectados con rapidez y el virus no ha
salido del circuito cerrado a la
población local noruega ha encabezado el
medallero seguida por alemania y con
china en la tercera posición ha sido su
mejor resultado en toda la historia de
aquí salen estrellas como su semen o
especialmente el link que se alistó en
el equipo chino después de abandonar el
estado en sevilla y es todo un fenómeno
también ha acaparado cortadas pero por
razones muy diferentes la deportista
rusa valiera envuelta en un oscuro caso
de dopaje y que a sus 15 años no pudo
superar la presión y fracaso en las
finales de patinaje